je peux comprendre les inquiétudes qui
ont été suscitées par ce service dans
les rédactions
parce qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas
pour l'état de labelliser les médias ou
d'orienter le choix des français vers
tel ou tel média en tant que ministre de
la culture garant de la liberté de la
presse
garant de son indépendance et du
pluralisme de la presse je souhaite donc
vous annoncer que le gouvernement a pris
la décision de retirer cette page du
site du gouvernement
j'en profite enfin pour saluer le
travail remarquable des journalistes
pendant la crise qui ont contribué
malgré les difficultés à informer nos
compatriotes et à lutter efficacement
contre les des informations